soirée vers merci d'être avec nous
nouvelle manifestation donc on le disait
avec december chemise mais environ 66%
des aides
c'est ce que vous craignez pourquoi ces
baisses pourquoi c'est le décès c'est
très facile à expliquer on avait
actuellement dans la pac actuelle avec 4
dead au verdissement peu à peu près tous
les agriculteurs touchent et environ 132
euros en moyenne pour toutes les
productions
c'est en moyenne sur toute la france par
hectare ld qu'on appelait d'ado maintien
pour les réducteurs qui était longue bio
donc on était à plus de 200 euros 210
euros d aides à l'hectare pour la bio et
là le gouvernement a proposé que les led
pour les allées le temps de nous soit
110 euros par hectare donc si on fait le
calcul on a une baisse de 66% des aides
à l'hectare pour l'ensemble des
producteurs view de france
ça semble être géré en galère quand on
vous écoute tout simplement une volte
face parce que vous dites voilà il ya
une baisse mais on ne se l'expliqué pas
vraiment d'autant qu'on est souvent me
tuer à des messages qui encourage
consommateurs français à à bien manger
donc pourquoi cette espèce de
revirements départ du gouvernement
le revirement du gouvernement s'est
aussi à l'affluence du syndicat
majoritaire la fnsea qui compte non de
les coucher c'est à dire le petit verte
de la nouvelle pac aille à la majorité
des agriculteurs et pour cela oublier
prêté au même niveau que la hache
veilleux qui est donc un label aux
valeurs environnementales mais qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec le bio parce
que avec la jeu on peut utiliser des
pesticides utilisés les engrais
chimiques et les les
les conséquences les pour
l'environnement sont bien moindres que
ce qu'apporte la culture bio avec des
conséquences qu'on imagine
également négatif sur le consommateur
puisqu'il y aura forcément une
répercussion des prix et le consommateur
pourra peut-être d'en manger ou pour
plus cher puisque ce que notre
revendication elle porte sur une chose
très simple c'est de dire que
l'agriculture
l'agriculteur y produit de la nourriture
pour les consommateurs et la culture bio
en même temps par semaine qu'il fait il
protège une c'est un certain nombre de
biens communs qui sont l'eau la
biodiversité le climat et que c'est bien
commun ils doivent être rémunérés par
l'ensemble de la société et donc par les
aides nous nous c'est pas des aides pour
economics et dz par rapport à notre
travail pour qu'on reconnaisse la
qualité du travail qu'on fait par
rapport à l'environnement
et si ya pas d aide forcément on va
répercuter cette part qui est sociale
collective sur les produits avec des
conséquences sur la cherté des produits
la capacité de pouvoir développer ses
produits vers la restauration collective
favoriser l'importation de produits de
pays tiers etc etc
le président je vous en prie le
président de la république un fait en ce
moment barbon et son tour de france pour
pour aller au plus près des citoyens
provinciaux dit il qu'il connaît moi
vous dit également que son arrivée au
pouvoir a sonné
la fin du développement de l'agriculture
biologique
pour quelles raisons la raison est
simple c'est que en fait jusqu'à présent
à une théologie qui était soutenu par le
financement de l'état en particulier et
aussi des régions
et quand il arrivait en 2017 il a
supprimé la part de l'état sur l'aide au
maintien led qui permet des leaders qui
jouent depuis plusieurs années alors
nous aurons nouvelle aquitaine on a eu
beaucoup de chance on a travaillé très
bien avec région nouvelle aquitaine
parce que à l'époque ces aides a été
distribué région donc notre durant a
pris la part de ea compenser la pta pour
que l'ensemble des paysans bio de
nouvelles aquitaine est une ado maintien
jusqu'à la fin de cette pac mais mais le
président macro n'a fait aucun effort
pour en développer la pac dans sa
politique eric vous avez clairement
l'impression aujourd'hui qu'on vous
punit au détriment peut-être de ceux qui
travaillent avec vos mauvaises pratiques
agricoles c'est vers cette tendance là
je sais pas si on peut les missions je
pense que moi je suis revenu depuis plus
de 25 ans et j'ai le sentiment depuis
très longtemps que l'agriculture
biologique fait peur à un certainement à
une frange d'agriculteurs et de
développent de développement agricole
d'agrochimie qui ne sont pas capables de
faire face à notre technicité à notre
façon de produire à notre façon de voir
le vivant un autre façon de considérer
le bien-être animal
un autre façon de faire attention à
l'université à l'environnement et
effectivement il ya une pression
extrêmement fortes contre ce mode
ce mode agricole tout une sphère
économique
mais par contre on a la chance d'avoir à
côté de nous des consommateurs qui nous
plaît vite site et territoires qui nous
plébiscite qui se rend bien compte que
l'agriculture biologique c'est une
solution
pour le traitement de l'eau pour tous
tout une transition agricole qui devient
nécessaire
merci d'avoir été avec nous gérons
keller on savoir à exposer vos
revendications en direct sur arte france